so uh Kevin Hart is currently facing a
sixty million dollar lawsuit from the
woman that was in the sex tape with him
in 2017 originally when the sex tape
came out she and her lawyer weren't
going to press charges against Kevin
because they said that he was also a
victim in the situation and now she's
coming out saying that the person who
recorded the sex tape is working with
Kevin Hart and they wanted publicity for
his irresponsible tour that's what she's
claiming now oh yeah cuz he wanted to
risk his entire family and fortune on us
getting caught with some chicken head
leave Kevin Hart alone and she knew the
people involved in this I mean makes her
money is that they I'd love to see that
16 well that's what she looks like
yeah yeah clicked on her which one this
one friend of Mines friends with her I
think she looks really good in this
picture who brought one no she thought
in all of them she looks like God what's
her [ __ ] name she ain't innocent no
somebody's guilty for being hurt looking
for money
God what's her name Maris from she's in
hitch the girl hitch Gosselin Eva little
B that Eva Mendes by better body though
he or she does yeah that's my she's
smoked it dude it's a sex party of Kevin
Hart the biggest rock star in the world
so yeah yeah wait what's that what daddy
likes
dude 60 million 69 or so it hurt my
feelings for 60 million yeah she's
smoked show that person I would also get
that person says her lawyer scumbags but
that's what lawyers loser Laura I
believe it's that woman who represents
all woman's like this Lisa bloom yeah
I'm sure she's standing up for yeah she
seems great it's all about money you
haven't heard a great [ __ ] human
being I know you did have sex are you
not here you know best like 60 nice
great Oh God
so no way for sex Jesus Christ in the
car - you'll have to pay her off - shut
her up ya little five mil make it go
away
enjoy your money that's probably what
happen huh oh that's that's funny yeah
that's a 60-mile then the sell for two
or three home girls get paid or less and
rightfully so
right huh no keep going show you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]